[Music]
it's a concert festival promising luxury
accommodations a list entertainers like
cardi B migos future and Trey Songz and
it's supposed to be happening right now
but here's what it looked like yesterday
the Stovall
a three-day gathering in northeastern
Belgium was canceled Friday just as
concert goers were arriving at the venue
in a tweet organizers said the local
mayor would not let the festival begin
and as safety was an issue rapper ASAP
rocky tweeted he would not be performing
due to infrastructure and security
problems angry spectators told there
would be no festival got unruly while
others lashed out on social media many
pointing out that they spent thousands
of dollars on tickets as well as travel
organizers say they are now consulting
about offering a refund if this all
sounds familiar
it should in 2017 fire festival Lord
thousands of concert goers to the
Bahamas only to strand them with little
food and no music when organizers could
not provide enough basic services for
the guests while it's still unclear what
prompted Vesta Ville to be called off
there is another common thread between
the two ill-fated concerts yeah what it
is it's the are you early catch me June
29 jump baby rapper Ja Rule a founder of
fire festival was slated to perform at
Bestival this weekend just a just a
rotten combination you you canceled
someone's good weekend you take their
money and you have a situation where you
have all of those people and they're
angry and so it just people did not feel
safe maybe the shot rule takes a brief
step away just a little bit yeah